well election day is nearly upon us and  if you haven't registered to vote yet  will the fourth Tuesday of September is  National voter registration day the  National Association of secretaries of  State started the event back in 2012.  now it's coordinated it's a coordinated  effort from local state and National  organizations to urge people all over to  register to vote  and here in Nevada there are several  ways you at home can register to vote  you can first register online at  registertovote.nv.gov you can also mail  in the voter registration form or the  easiest way register in person at your  local election office remember election  day is November 8th